So I spent my entire adult life
searching.
Searching for meaning, wondering
meaning, wondering why it is that we're even alive.
And I say my entire adult life because that hasn't always been the case.
I grew up in the western suburbs of Melbourne and I can tell you that the only searching that was going on was for the
the next party
next party. And the only questioning,
"Are we drinking beer, or bourbon and coke?"And this all changed
all changed at
-ged at eighteen years old. I was taken on a four day Outward Bound
style hike
And I'm embarrassed, really embarrassed
to tell you that I actually, I hated it. I hated it
that hike almost broke me. I wasn't in good enough
I wasn't in good enough shape, and at the end of each day I just felt beaten
and weak and incompetent. There was
There was only
There was only one consolation. On the last night
we got sent out. Those of you familiar with Outward Bound will know about the solo.
We got sent out to be on our own for the night. We got sent out with no sleeping bags,
no food, 'part save for a bag of flour
flour. And no water. And a box of matches. And you had to survive the night.
the night. Now a lot of the
Now a lot of the other guys that were on this course couldn't make it. They scurried back
back to the main camp during the night. And that night I fell in
I fell into my element. I discovered this, this peace that
peace that, take everything away and I can be OK. And that night
And that night I actually, I felt this connection. I felt overco- overcome by this connection.
By this connection and for one of the first times in my life
I actually felt at home
home. For the next decade I, I
...I've...I've drifted in and out of actually, of feeling, chasing that connection do-
that connection down. And periods of being lost where I would switch back
switch back to my old ways. In April
1997 found me once again lost.
And whenever I've had that feeling before I did what I had always
had always done. And I reached for my backpack and my hiking boots. I'd
I'd heard about an island called Hinchinbrook island off the coast of the Great Barrier
Barrier Reef in the northeast of Australia. And, what I'd heard about Hinchinbrook Island is
Hinchinbrook Island is that it was this amazing wilderness island. And to get across you have
you have to catch a ferry boat across. It takes a couple of hours.
And when I say ferry boat, right. For those of you that have cruised the Greek islands like
Forget uh- thousands of passengers, I'm talking a boat that can hold twelve people max.
max. And so I
And so I catch the ferry boat across and I start hiking. And at the end of the
first day. I come to a beach and I met a guy on the beach who introduces himself as
as ?Gert Van Kolen?, a Dutchman. And ?Gert? tells me what he wants to
His plan is to climb to the top of the island's tallest peak, Mount Bowen
Mount Bowen. And I gotta tell you, when you look across from the mainland
at Hinchinbrook Island, Mount Bowen dominates. Absolutely dominates.
Absolutely dominates. And so before, as soon as ?Gert? started telling me about his
and I didn't really have to wait for him to ask me. I knew I was in.
I, I, I'm in. I'm a- all over this.
this. We break camp at first thing the next morning and we start
making our way up the side of Mount Bowen. Now there's something that I should point out
out. There's no trail to the top of Mount Bowen. All
All right, we're on a wilderness island. So the way that you get to the top is that you follow a creek bed up.
And you- you bushwhack and you boulder hop
and this is what we did all day. We found a place
place to set up camp for the night and strung up a tarpaulin in case it
rained. We were kind of. Yeah we were kind of tough hiking boys, we were way beyond tents.
We set the tarpaulin up and cook dinner. ?Gert? had just got into his sleeping bag.
I was just about to climb into mine when I realize, 'hang on a minute
minute before I do that...I need to
use a bathroom.' Which is kind of nuts because there are no bathrooms in the middle of
a wilderness island, but basically I needed to take a leak.
If you've ever spent much time in the back country you'll know that it's not really a good idea
to go and take a leak into
a creek that your water supply. Especially
when you're coming back down the same way in a couple of days.
So I figured you know, what the best way for me to move uh, far enough away from this creek is I should
uh, make my way to the other side and I should mention the creek at this point is literally just a trickle
trickle tunning down the center. And on the other side is a steep rock
wall about twelve or fourteen foot high and I thought,
that's perfect I can scramble up over that, I'll be fine. So I make my way across and
as luck would have it, at least I thought it was luck,
I found a crack. I got my hands in that crack. I got
my left hand up as high as I could. Got my other hand in the crack, put my right foot
up against the wall and as I pulled up the world literally gave way.
As I've
pulled up a, um a refrigerator-sized piece of rock broke
broke loose from the rock wall and absolutely slammed
me back down into that creek bed. And I'm talking slammed. I was instantly. In this
world of pain. I just-- I screamed out. ?Gert?
?Gert? came running across to be greeted by the scene of me
from the hips down underneath this huge piece of rock and things got pretty frantic
at that point. Right? I can't even begin to describe
what that pain
felt like it. Just this incredible pain just grinding, grinding down into my legs. And there's only
one thing going through my mind, I need this thing off me. I need it off me right now.
So I'm pushing at it. Gert jumped in beside me. We are both pushing at this thing with all, all our
might. I feel like I'm going to tear
myself in half. But nothing's happening. Nothing's happening.
You know when something really serious happens, there's only two ways that things are gonna go. You're either
You're either going to freak. Or things are gonna get crystal clear. And luckily for me, things
became crystal clear. I
I took charge. I told ?Gert? what he needed to do. We started out, we tried a series of levers to
to lift the rock. It didn't work. We start, we tried using a wedge-shaped stone
wedge-shaped stone driven by another stone as a hammer stone to try and lift it that way.
that way. Didn't work. Nothing worked.
Just when I thought
when I thought things couldn't get any worse, I felt the first few drops of rain. Now
Now I'm in a creek bed. Those drops
Those drops turned into a torrential downpour. And within forty five minutes I had water
water swirling around my hips. Within an hour and a half I had a raging
flooding creek up around my waist. And
And things got desperate. ?Gert? had started to build a dam.
I'm starting to think back about my new backpack. With
it has the same kind of
of frame as a previous backpack I had used before that had an
aluminum frame made out of aluminum tubing. Because
I'm thinking, if it has I can take that and I can stretch it out. And I can use that as a snorkel when the
water goes over my head. Because
I'm convinced the water is going over my head because I can see by the high water mark on the wall
beside me that it's gone over my head before.
As suddenly as it had started
the rain stopped. Right, and then gradually
And gradually over the next couple of hours the water level started to subside. But
we still had a problem. I was still stuck underneath a one ton piece of
rock.
[pause]
I spent the longest night of my life before we decided that ?Gert? would hike
out in the morning. That's the only way that I'm coming out. Is for him to hike out and organize
a rescue.
As the sun come up the next morning, I watched Gert pack together his things. He packed
he packed together some things for me. We put him in a plastic bag and, and slung
it uh, over my shoulders around my neck in case the water would come
up again while he was gone.
Here's this guy. I can tell you, I have never ever ever felt so lonely as watching this guy, hugging this guy
goodbye and watching him turn around and hike back down off that
mountain. Because I know I'm going to be there for at least another 24
hours on my own. He's gotta make it back down to the beach
where we'd met the day before.
before. He's then gotta hike back along the beach
to where the ferry boat dropped us off. The ferry boat then only comes in
once a day. Right? I knew I was staring down the barrel
of my ultimate test. So
So after.
after he went I did the only thing that I could do and I settled in to wait.
To wait. And to think. Alright.
I thought about all the people that I would probably never see again. Actually wrote letters
to some of those people. I wrote letters to my mum and dad. I didn't think I'd
ever be seeing them again.
I got angry. Actually, I got really angry.
I wondered why I couldn't be happy staying at home
watching T.V. and mowing the lawn on a Sunday afternoon like a lot of my friends that I grew up with.
up with. Why couldn't I be satisfied with that? Why did I always have to be
traveling around the world? Chasing, chasing. Looking for something. Searching. And then I
And then I remembered, "Ah the connection. Chasing
the connection. Then I'd think, "Great."
"How's this? Is this connected enough for ya?"
They're going to find you out here in a couple of days dead."
"dead. Under this rock."
under this rock." And then I would pull myself out from that- that, from that
trough and bring myself and psych myself that y'know, "You've gotta hang in there, you're gonna get through this." And I rode
rode that rollercoaster ride all
all day and all of the next night. By the next morning I'd started
to hallucinate. I thought I was hallucinating when I saw a, a
a red pool around my right foot. I could actually see my right foot the way I was trapped. And I thought,
"This is interesting, it's a little late now to start bleeding." And then I saw why.
I saw a nipper of a freshwater crayfish pop
up out of the water. And I couldn't believe it. I just thought, "You opportunistic bastard! How"
"How dare"
you
"you take on a guy that stuck under a refrigerator-sized"
piece of rock like that." I couldn't believe the cheek of that guy, and I spent the next couple of hours trying to kill
him with a long stick. [laughter] Now
you
you gotta remember, now as this is happening I'm starting to think that I'm in some kind of David Lynch movie. Just when I
when I thought that it couldn't get any more
bizarre, I felt a sting -- in my groin. And then
And then another sting. And I started swatting ants.
ants.
I looked down and realized that I had quite a few ants running all
over me. And I noticed to my horror
a trail that lead
back to a now-exposed nest that
was behind this refrigerator-sized piece of rock
rock that I was now underneath and I realized that these guys were actually
looking for a new home. And I freaked. Right, I
Right, I just freaked.
I, I, I just had visions because by now I'm starting to lose it and I knew that I couldn't let myself
go to sleep. I thought that if you go to sleep now you might not wake up. And I just had visions of, of,
of, of these ants getting into my ears and my eyes and it was like a horror movie. I freaked.
I remembered that in my first aid kit I had a tube of, of bug goop. And I
And I prayed that ?Gert? had put that first aid kit in the plastic bag, around my
my neck and he had. I pulled out that goop and I'm tellin' ya I just rubbed it all over my
my face-all over my, my head. All over my clothes. I rubbed it into my eyes. I didn't
I didn't care how much it stung, I just covered myself in the stuff and hoped
that it would work. And eventually I
dr-drifted off.
I woke up
I woke up to the sound of a helicopter.
And I don't think I've ever been so happy to see another human being as ?Chief Jeff?
as the paramedic made his way towards me and started to stabilize me. Two more guys
came down and they spent the next two and a half hours lifting
this rock off me before they winched me into a helicopter and sped me straight
to Cairns Base Hospital. [pause] I woke
I woke up
the following afternoon into a whole new world.
world. Right, I woke up minus both legs, amputated.
at mid-thigh. And so begun my new life.
life.
life. I had to learn how to do everything again. I had to learn how to use
wheelchair. I had to learn how to use prosthetic legs. But
at, at
at the same time I was, I was driven by this, by this purpose. The clarity
that had come to me under the rock was still with me. And so I pushed,
pushed, pushed to just reclaim all these different parts of my life. But there was one
thing, one burning question away in the back of my mind. And that was
And that was, "This is
great but am I ever going to feel that connection again? Am I ever going to experience
a wild place? Experience nature on its own terms?
Is there
anyway that that can happen?" I eventually discovered that you can put
fat wheels, mountain bike wheels onto a wheelchair.
I said, "Where, where do I get'em?" [laughter]
I started quote, unquote hiking and it was on one of those
first hikes. I'd just hiked five miles and I'd just had my
first swim. In a, in a water hole in a river -- my first swim outside of a swimming
pool -- and this light bulb got off and I, I
I thought, "If I can do this already, I wonder if I could climb"
"I could climb a mountain. I wonder if a guy with no legs could climb a mountain?"
And I got this picture of a mountain in Tasmania that I'd climbed twice before called Cradle Mountain.
And it had taken me about five hours car to car. And I thought, "D'you know what? There is only one way
to find out."
So I started training. And a couple of months later. [pause] Just
Just ten months after losing both legs, I set out from the parking
lot and over the course of two and a half days I wheeled, I dragged
I dragged, I scraped, I crawled on my guts at times, until
I got to sit on top of Cradle Mountain.
[pause] And, I
I gotta tell ya, sitting on top of that mountain I just got completely, completely
overwhelmed with emotion. I felt like I'd got hit by a semi trailer-load
of emotions. Everything came flooding back at me--the accident, the
the rescue. The months and months of, of, of rehabilitation. Everything that I'd
Everything that I'd lost. But in that moment, I realized
I realized, that I might have
lost my legs, but I'd gained so, so,
so much more.
The thing that most overwhelmed me was that feeling of being connected.
And I realized in that moment that I'd actually found my way home. Thank
you. [applause]
[applause]